[Music]
sophie she's not here yet
fathers play a big role in their
daughter's life
it's a special bond that only they share
and even when she's all grown up she's
still
not his little girl
done
i have something to say i'm engaged
[Music]
[Applause]
and i propose oh
you proposed yes you proposed to him he
didn't propose to you can you do that
does anyone do that
you both have been coming here for over
a year do you still want this marriage
to work or not
i'm here now
[Music]
we're supposed to play the perfect
family until sophie gets married oh we
can say sorry to spoil your happiness
but we're getting a divorce muscle tough
mommy poppy this is alan castillo we
don't want some big fancy wedding and we
want to pay for it two lawyers are out
of college working for a non-profit is
gonna pay for the wedding billy i'm the
father of the bride and i will be paying
for the wedding and i'm gonna be walking
my daughter down the aisle the wedding
planners see in 20 minutes what are you
planning i left amelia
so what are we thinking about theme feed
we don't want a catholic quitting what
are you talking about you're going to
officiate then my guide monika from the
zen center new york so yoga class is set
up a wedding i caramba
this is my father for the wedding oh my
god how rick is this guy can have some
champagne and come aboard what is he a
bond villain
we should go over the ground rules can
we all hands we can
can we dance if necessary how about a
kiss absolutely not
daddy what is the budget that we're
working with
our mother
yes
i really like him he's nothing like us
maybe that's the point we don't watch
sports no you play sports i like hiking
things have been coming at me very fast
it's time for me to embrace the future i
got your back showtime baby
we dance
[Applause]
[Music]
ready yes and you
no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you